I would hate it as wilders
is going to respond in the country
I SAY that very honestly
because he stands
for 1 society that I have a lot of trouble with
he thinks his freedom
just
at the expense of the lack of freedom of others
reached and there I am
Fundamentally disagree
that goes much further than programs or whatever
but i like that
it has been chosen so clearly on the right
uh in the elections
that and those 4 parties
said to each other immediately after the elections
we want to try it together
that must fail in sight of the whole of the Netherlands
before we get to something else
ehm eh police party of the strawberry
eh our responsible will never incur
but it is
outside just unlikely that soon
was discussed